surprise [ __ ] okay
yeah we started two minutes earlier
there's no intro no not for not for side
tracks
i don't have a i don't have an intro for
that okay i'm not cool enough to okay
we'll have to get one we'll have to get
one going
that'd be cool yeah you think what what
should it what should it be
[ __ ] you're gonna put me on a spot now i
gotta come gotta imagine what it is
right yeah come on that's what you're
good at
thinking on your feet picture me
sleeping
well i i video a live action video about
live action it's just like that andy
warhol movie
[Laughter]
was it like eight hours long or
something
[Laughter]
i know it's like well like i said i'm
usually like really you know we're
sitting here
and talking about [ __ ] but then he's
just kind of like
just start it yeah i'm like but it's
still like three minutes he's like who
cares it doesn't matter
everybody's in there everybody's up
there yeah nobody's going to come in and
go what do we miss
zach's in there everybody's in there
let's see who else is here
they're still coming in i appreciated
manga's uh
thing earlier saying hey honky tonks
yeah
he has no idea what the [ __ ] he's saying
well like i said i mean i know what a
honky tonk is but i don't know why it's
called that
i never really think i never really
thought about it talk is a talk i i
think
is a it's a bastardization of the word
talk
this is these are bars where all the
honky's getting together talking that's
what that is
trying to pick up other lives dancing
yeah
trying to pick up other people's wives
and [ __ ]
senator says happy twin peaks day jenny
thank you very much
i it probably would have been a good day
to open my big huge twin peaks
you know all the all of the shows but i
have still haven't [ __ ] watched that
because i feel like
i feel like when i watch that i want to
watch it
i mean i've seen like the first and
second season obviously
but i want to re-watch it because it's
been a long time yeah so i kind of want
a couple of days that i can just block
out you know get some booze get some
snacks
and i can just sit there and watch the
whole [ __ ] thing and not have to do
anything else
so i don't see that never happen so i
mean i never have a couple of these
where i don't have to do anything
so you know it's cause you're constantly
busy you got a lot of [ __ ] well yeah
that's what i mean
hold on maybe once the cookbook is done
i'll be able to do it oh he's gonna
i told him to go get the michael kane
wig but he was like no that's only for
that's only for special occasions
special occasions
put my [ __ ] booney cap on i was
hoping it'd wake me up a little bit
how can you be sleepy i don't know man
what time did you get up [ __ ]
hormones or something i don't know what
uh
man you guys oh scott says make sure you
watch firewalk with me before season
three i will i've seen it before a
couple times and i have it on
uh on blu-ray i think you got it for me
for christmas or my birthday or
something
a couple like a while back yeah so yeah
i'll rewatch that again before
i'll i'll do it right i'll watch it in
like the correct order like you're
supposed to watch
it what is it twin peaks right the first
two seasons and then you're supposed to
watch
firewalk with me which is like you know
a prequel kind of
okay and then but he's saying watch that
before you watch season three i haven't
seen season three yet
um because like i said wasn't it on
showtime and we don't have showtime
no so i never did get to see it so then
finally finally like this past year i
was like you know what i'm gonna buy
myself a [ __ ] christmas present
and they had a this big thing right here
that had all this
i probably showed this before but this
big thing right here that had all three
seasons on it i think it was like 50
bucks
so i bought it so you know what i was
going on with you guys i did my [ __ ]
taxes yesterday
i'm so happy that they're done
and i'm happy that i didn't have to pay
as much as i thought i was going to
it's always so alarming when i do them
because you know i'm self-employed so i
have to do
so i usually have to pay so it's
you know used to be back in the old days
when i got a refund
that must be nice um you know i would i
would do my [ __ ] taxes immediately
like as soon as [ __ ] february first
rolled around i'd be like yeah give me
that money but now
now i like wait till let's [ __ ] bid
it because i know i'm gonna have to pay
but it wasn't it wasn't bad this year it
wasn't too bad um
you know not not as bad as the first i
think the first year i did it
self-employed i think i had to pay 500
something
sent a link to some kind of british show
with the dude saying hello honky ducks i
don't think he knows
he doesn't know what he's talking about
either he looks like damn
what's his name what i don't know
little comedy show that
like benny hill or something yeah i
couldn't really see it it's it's little
it's not benny hill it's somebody else
i'm benny hill
used to watch [ __ ] benny hill they
played on reruns out in california
mostly because they'd have a stripper on
there at least [ __ ] once a day well
yeah you get to watch like
halfway through these girls like like
damn
like bubbling around yeah like bubbling
around
yeah yeah they weren't a bastard
they weren't they weren't bashful about
it man british knew what was up they
liked boobies
yeah that was back when bbc actually had
good programming on it
it stands for boobalicious
i
boob
central
i don't know i remember my dad liking it
a lot like back in the 70s i think they
showed it on pbs which is hilarious
because that's supposed to be like
educational england has some good
genetic stock man
that [ __ ] saxon bloodlines man
yeah you can't be in that ethnic group
[ __ ] if you're under [ __ ]
[ __ ] d cup well you for sure can't be
on benny hill no
definitely not without no they were
[ __ ] there's kind of like a whole
strain
of i guess it's kind of passe now but
there was kind of a whole strain of
that type of humor yeah i just feel like
a lot of that there was a lot of that
type of humor like in the 60s and 70s in
the uk
those are some [ __ ] double g [ __ ]
stat style women going on there man
yeah david june says benny hill was
shown after old doctor who on pbs where
i live yeah i think here too
like and they showed monty python's
flying circus also
that's back when tom baker was was
doctor who man that was my doctor who
when i grew up with well that's the one
i remember the best too because my
cousin used to be super into it when we
were kids and he would watch it
yeah there was a blonde guy that that
played him after he was okay
but uh no man [ __ ] tom baker that was
[ __ ] doctor who
peter cushing was doctor who too i never
saw those though that was just the
movies
i don't think there was a television pro
i'm not sure there was a television show
with uh peter cushing in it i don't
remember him being i think it was just
movies
now i'm intrigued you didn't know that i
don't really remember that yeah peter
cushing was doctor who for a while
that seems like something i should have
known are you sure that's correct
yeah i'm pretty sure yeah okay i'm not
i'm not doubt i'm just saying
yeah yeah peter cushing was in two films
okay
so he was like i said he wasn't on the
tv thing okay no no like i said i just
told you that
okay i don't think he was in tv just the
movies yeah he was only in the movies
all right well [ __ ] now i have to see
those i don't think i
saw clips from them they looked pretty
good had the dialects and [ __ ]
well anything with peter cushing in it
yeah i'll watch anything
the voices for the dialects are [ __ ]
hokey though they didn't really have
that down yet
yeah they kind of yeah but you know it's
like anything else that evolved
yeah oracle said it was a different
version of the character
he was actually okay okay that's really
weird
i don't know why i didn't know what
rebooting him yeah
well i mean you can kind of do that with
that character because
you know because of kind of his
backstory or his origin or whatever you
can kind of do whatever you want there
was continuity though
yeah you know like usually he remembered
stuff that had happened to him before
that kind of stuff
anyway um we got to see
the uh last night well started two
nights ago we started watching the old
uh
omen series look i even wore my shirt
like
the television program left the movie
just lift the lift up a little bit
that's things me on the show yeah the um
putting that [ __ ] on blast
oh yeah saw the first one
and then last night we saw the the
second two they were good
they were better than i remembered them
yeah they well what happened was hulu
added the first one in the second one
and then i thought they added the third
one too but they did that little thing
where the no the third one you have to
have the stars
upgrade you know what i mean which is
like an extra three bucks a month or
something
and we're like ah and so like we had to
get at amazon prime and rent it for 3.99
to see the third one because by that
point we were all kind of like
yeah wanted to see the third one well
[ __ ] we want to see the third one we
were going to do like a whole trilogy
yeah but they had it they had it on
amazon prime though yeah yeah you just
had to run it it wasn't
it was 3.99 it was 3.99 yeah and uh
really uh
i think the third i think the third
movie was the best one i didn't remember
the third one
as being that good the third one was
much better than i remember
yeah jerry goldsmith did the uh the
score did the school damn neal was in it
when he was
quite young yeah it had an epic [ __ ]
score it was like something out of red
like a satanic raiders of the lost ark
had done pretty good
um i remembered seeing it like on hbo
when i was a kid
yeah and i remember thinking that it was
just real cheap
cheap looking cheap feeling that's
because you know [ __ ] you know
the transfer of the video was that was
shitty but if you see it now you know in
hd
the way it was way it was intended to be
seen in a theater man with the [ __ ]
good audio it was good really like wow
it looks like a real movie yeah
i would say i it's hard to beat
omen one but in some ways i think it was
better than omen one
i don't know if i'd go that far but it
did have a lot of cool [ __ ] to it
the only thing about the third one that
i don't like is that the ending is kind
of anticlimactic
yeah it just kind of starts it just ends
of jesus shows up
the holy spirit shows leather alert i
mean this came out in 1981 though
yeah and there was some [ __ ] that they
that i would have done like
in the third movie about halfway through
it
i would have had a scene where damien is
actually talking to satan
maybe you don't see him maybe you only
see satan from the profile kind of like
vader and the emperor talking from you
know
uh what's this empire strikes back
something like that
because satan should have been a damn
character in it but they didn't want to
go there
i guess not it's really weird because i
mean there there is a scene with damien
who as i said has played as an adult by
sam neal
and he's in his what i called his
fortress of satan tude
um which i guess was the attic of his
house looked like
i couldn't tell um so he's up there and
he talks to satan
but you can't really tell if satan's
like talking back to him or
you know he's just up there like talking
like hey dad what's up you know he
didn't say anything like that but you
know what i mean
can we talk for a second because i want
to talk more about three yeah as well
yeah that was called the final conflict
the final conflict the final comments
moment three the final
i actually liked it it was it um
it's it's kind of a bigger budget movie
had some ray harry housing [ __ ] style
miniatures and [ __ ]
uh cool statues you know in the [ __ ] of
babylon statues some underground scenes
guys get crushed they had a
they had some elements in there that
were like something a little bit out of
star wars like
they had a group of uh priests catholic
priests that were
kind of like a kind of like a mafia
assassination squad
trying to home in on [ __ ] the
antichrist
take him out the monk foo assassination
gang
yeah they were from all over the world
you know they were from italy and
germany and one of them was from africa
a black dude from africa
and they all had their [ __ ] robes
they're doing all their [ __ ] and
they had to get their hands on the damn
the shanty dagger
[Laughter]
[Music]
they had seven of these damn daggers
from the first movie
people haven't seen the golden child
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
[Laughter]
they had to get those daggers and uh it
was pretty cool
and uh oh my god thank you ken hit a
jackpot holy [ __ ]
yep dinner drinks on me god damn you're
pretty awesome dude
he um there was uh you come on man you
gave me starstruck hold on
all right knocks the wind right here
yeah not the window so they're trying to
kill him
and all kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
happens he had satanic powers
uh the only thing that they should have
done
is and uh man they showed some of the
satanic mind control what it looked like
from the point of view if you were under
mind control remember the woman's baby
yeah that was pretty funny that's
[ __ ] weird killing a baby with an
iron
yeah they don't really show they don't
show it but when she
visualizes that yeah that's pretty it's
[ __ ] weird creepy and then um
a lot of baby killing in this one yeah
baby kill you had to kill the baby
because the [ __ ] nazarene was being
bored yeah he's like one of these is
jesus wipe them all out yeah
yeah it's that kind of thing i kind of
like to think the third one was the best
and had that big jerry goldsmith [ __ ]
score it was the score it was great
yeah it was like and he wrote that wrote
the original two the original score
so he was able to kind of go back with
all that
all the [ __ ] weird crop noises when
you see the animals and [ __ ] yeah
and then christine
i can't sing like that
yeah yeah that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so right now
you know
it really it really does does give it a
okay now i will say
here's something that bothered me about
the third one though one
the ending was a little anticlimactic
we'll get into that
two there's a little bit of a
continuity-ish
issue with the first one uh oh uh oh
what happened did it no not already come
on i'm good
i'm good over here all right did you did
you defrag that thing i did
no you did today yes i did okay i did
and i restarted it a couple times too
oh my god don't you don't
we're gonna lose it you guys i hope we
don't lose it
i don't know it's not looking too good
it's not looking too good
well they still got the audio is it
going on yours
they're saying it's good they're saying
it's good on this thing it's totally
frozen on this computer
maybe it'll well you know it never it's
kind of it's kind of moving it's kind of
it never froze on mine yeah weird so
it's just
us well we're just gonna keep going
until the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
okay it came back okay i don't know what
the deal is with that [ __ ]
it's weird huh you're on notice laptop
i you know i talked to my uh inanimate
objects
but no what i was going to say was that
there's a continuity issue with the
first
movie and here it is in the third one
you have the monk foo assassination gang
right calling the monk
yeah and well you know and they each
have one
of the daggers right and
the implication being that any one of
them that has the daggers
can kill damien yeah i thought
in the first movie didn't uh buckenhagen
told uh gregory peck
told him that's how he talks i love i
love him
oh think exactly some reason for some
reason your shit's locked up
yeah well you're way behind in tracks
well we'll see what happens like i said
i'm just gonna like let it [ __ ]
do its thing i'm gonna let it go i'm
gonna hope it works itself out
yeah so i don't have to have a meltdown
that laptop needs to feel some shame
yeah sure that's what you should feel
i'm not i'm not looking at you guys i'm
looking for the laptop yeah watch if i
touch this don't
i don't have any notes so i don't have
to touch that okay but yeah so
i thought in the first movie bugenhagen
told um
what did i i just said his name i forgot
the name of gregory peck
that is like you have to take damian and
you have to put him on the church altar
yeah and you i thought you had to use
all the daggers like in a cross
formation for the [ __ ] to work i just
didn't think you could just take one of
the
daggers and just like [ __ ] stab him
and he's dead but that's kind of what
happened to the third one though because
some of the daggers get lost
yeah some get buried and everything yeah
so
obviously you don't need all of them no
just as long as it was a mortal wound
evidently although
maybe okay maybe because i don't know if
you know this but they made a fourth one
although i think it went direct to it
was a tv movie or if you went to direct
to whatever you survived
i yeah maybe it was just kind of like
you win this time jesus
you know what i mean maybe it was that
kind of thing although it kind of looked
like he died at the end but maybe not
now they never really resolved it he
looked like he died but that was he just
laid there
there's a big spoon but he only got
stabbed like where he got stabbed
got stabbed in the heart didn't he from
the back well maybe i don't it was kind
of hard to tell
it looked a little low for the heart but
maybe not i'm not i'm not an anatomist
it was
it was still a good movie yeah i liked
it a lot um yeah
the second one was good they were all
good they were all good movies
um i think the i think the second one
was the weakest one
out of them yeah but that doesn't mean
it was a weak movie
although the second one segment had some
good [ __ ] in it
the second one had all of the like the
a lot of the acting was really kind of
like over the top and campy kind of in
that late 70s kind of way
and also some of the deaths in the
second one
were ridiculous and awesome
i mean especially that one chick uh she
was like a um
what was she she was like a journalist
the one that wore that big red thing all
the time
and her getting tippy-headrened by that
[ __ ]
crow or raven or whatever and it's like
it came in it packed her eyes out
and then she didn't have any eyes now
so she was like in a ditch on the side
of the road so she crawls in a road and
gets [ __ ] hit by a semi
and it's like she not only gets hit by a
semi the semi hits her
then it like throws her up she hits like
the front of the
you know the trailer of the semi i'm
kind of freezing up again
she hits the trailer of the semi and
then falls
on the road and then the semi fronts are
over yeah
i wonder if that actress was just kind
of like can i die with some dignity in
this [ __ ] movie please i mean oh my
god it's
like first i get [ __ ] attacked by a
bird and that looks ridiculous and i'm
like this [ __ ] truck
it was [ __ ] great and then remember
the one guy that works at the thorn
uh factory or facility or whatever and
he's in the elevator
and the elevator goes like all up and
down like really fast like the [ __ ]
tower of terror right
and then he thinks it's okay because it
stops and he's like shoot that was an
ordeal wasn't it and then all of a
sudden this cable snaps and comes down
and this cable is apparently made of
[ __ ]
i don't know what but it comes down
through the [ __ ] elevator car and
slices his ass in half
and it's just sliced in half and there's
like a really really nice shot of
him like up against the [ __ ] elevator
thing and he's like screaming and it's
like all his guts there and stuff ken
said that the uh
that in bougain hagan's pitch he said
the center one was the one
uh the key to extinguishing physical
life
right he's had to do his spirit the
other ones had so even so okay so even
if you got the one
and you got it in there that would just
kill the body yeah but it wouldn't
necessarily kill like the satan
spirit or whatever yeah right buddhica
boudicca the uh the third one has a
soundtrack that has a score i think
might be even even better
than this i really like the score for
the third one now the second one i did i
the score didn't stand out so i'm
assuming that jerry goldsmith didn't do
that one because usually you can tell a
jerry goldsmith's score they're pretty
distinctive
um you know he did the first one and the
third one
joe that wasn't a kid underneath the ice
that was an old man underneath the ice
yeah that's right the old guy that died
yeah and kids remember
he remembers the cable slice from the
elevator that was a good one too
the elevator weights that was a guy who
did the blood serum test
yeah yeah and he came back as jackal's
blood jackal blood
why does this kid have jackal and he
killed his ass
anybody who was getting ready to [ __ ]
unveil the demonic [ __ ] nature of him
[ __ ]
you got killed in real in like overtly
ridiculous like no one could just die
and like you know they fell down the
stairs at their house or something like
that they had
to be punished they had to make it like
super spectacular
yeah it had to be like a punishment also
makes it a better movie because like i
said everybody wants to see a dude get
sliced in half by an elevator cable yeah
i mean
the woman the woman that got killed by
the the raven though
it didn't look ridiculous i thought it
scared the [ __ ] of me when i was a kid
well yeah because i just it only got
ridiculous like the raven part wasn't
really that ridiculous because like i
said it was just like the birds
but then it was it was funny to me
because they just kept compounding it
yeah to the point where it's like the
bird pecked her eyes out that was bad
enough and then like
it was bad enough like for her not to
get just hit by the semi but to be
thrown up yeah into the like front of
the trailer
and then to fall off and then the truck
runs over
yeah it was so extra brutal
and she was in that down she was in that
[ __ ] room i don't know why that just
made me laugh
and she was in that damn red party girl
dress with the [ __ ] feathers and [ __ ]
well it was like a it was like a rough
or like a fur color
it's feathers i thought it was fur no
it's red fur was it fur or it didn't
matter
it was just something that you would
wear it looked like you're wearing a
nightclub back in the 60s
she had those high heels on she ran down
in the ditch and [ __ ] left him down
there she was in the mud she got up in
the [ __ ] road and hit her bow
she hit the back of the semi the [ __ ]
the little wind spoiler she hit that
blew off that [ __ ] got sucked up in the
side
in the side draft of the [ __ ] truck
as it was moving and it sucked her down
dear
dude in the rear set of wheels and ran
over or nearly ran over i don't think it
hit her
i think it just ran over her head i
think it was her legs it might
it was it was obviously a dummy yeah
well it didn't weigh much
and well they're not going to run over
the real action it didn't look like it
weighed much when it went through all
that
it was kind of funny but you know that's
the way movies were back then it scared
the [ __ ] out of me when i saw this kid
i just like i said i thought it was
funny because it just kept going
yeah it wasn't bad enough that she just
got running for a truck but then like
all of this ridiculous like [ __ ]
i don't understand what you're
complaining about this is the death
complaint
this is the [ __ ] devil i thought it
was [ __ ] devil's night that was
great the devil's not gonna [ __ ] make
this easy on you it's gonna be like one
humiliation
[ __ ] your eyes [ __ ] you boom boom boom
boom boom boom
she was screaming the whole time [ __ ]
you that's how you
do later on you know [ __ ] when damien
was a grown man he was like a sadist in
bed he crawled up on his girlfriend
[ __ ]
hey look wonder what happened to your
little um who knows i don't know
yeah oh well lost it lost it huh
yeah no this you probably still got it
no yeah nope
i'm gone gee it lasted a whole 31
minutes